welcome everyone i'm felicia day and
this is stranger things unlocked where
netflix geek gives you an exclusive look
into the shows you love
[Music]
and be warned there will be spoilers
today we flash up horror movies with the
duffer brothers a lot of times there are
these supernatural monsters but really a
lot of the horror comes from the humans
in the story break down joyce and
hopper's epic escape from siberia i
found my inner wolf
my inner russian bear
talk with millie bobby brown on set her
most valued thing that she has in her
life is her superpowers and taking that
away where does that leave us dive
deeper into lovers lake with swim team
captain steve harrington getting to do
that sort of stuff is like true
movie magic talk with sean levy about
directing that epic shootout we took the
time and we took the passion to make it
right
we roll the dice and unpack the dnd and
basketball mashup to end all mashups
which is so amazing
and
go behind the scenes on max's kate bush
powered mine layer escape
what do you say we crank things up to
11.
[Music]
now to get the nitty gritty on season
four directly from the masterminds
themselves please welcome the duffer
brothers matt and ross thank you so much
for being here oh thanks for having us
can you talk a little bit about the
adult themes and horror that have come
in as your cast have grown up is that a
factor in kind of like graduating the
horror with the children's age yeah
it really is i mean they've i you know
obviously when we started this show they
were so they were so little and so the
one of the big changes this year besides
our characters being in different
locations is that
the quote-unquote kids are now not kids
anymore and they're in high school
and so
suddenly
it opened up a lot of doors for us we
can't do the goonies fun adventure
anymore but what we can do is we can go
okay well now they can be in a horror
movie we can put them in
danger that is really scary and we can
look at
you know some of the movies that we love
growing up like nightmare on elm street
and hellraiser the stuff that we were
getting into when we were around that
age in high school we were just trying
to scare ourselves constantly yeah and
so we could infuse some of that in their
storyline and i think for the for the
first time for them it's like it's
really we want it to be really scary the
stuff going on with max and all this
it's like let's just push this and try
to be
as scary as possible and put them in the
middle of just a really a true horror
film yeah and i binged all of it
together and it is a beautiful
progression season to season how it gets
more uncomfortable and more
uncomfortable and finally in this one
i'm like what
did you intend on that yeah well i i
well yeah some of it is yeah it's them
growing older forces the show to evolve
forces us to change the writing and so
every season is completely different and
you know as rob's saying yeah they're co
they're going into high school
and that lends itself or reminds us of a
certain type of movie also middle school
for us was like a fun amazing joyful
experience like i have the some of the
best memories of my life most of them
were in middle school occurred in middle
school high school was horrible okay so
for us at least so i i have nothing but
terrible memories from high school most
stressful time in my life for us if
you're not in this you know we weren't
athletically gifted whatever we were in
the movies we grew up in a you know a
town that only cared about basketball so
it was not fun so it was anyway so it
just felt like okay this is where you
can explore depression and anxiety and
and you know all of that can be
represented by this monster vector so it
just felt um it felt right
it felt right to go a little it felt
like right to go darker also i think we
had just come off writing season three
and
which was our fun
pop
blockbuster summer season we wanted to
feel like a big blockbuster movie we
wanted a little bit silly we wanted
these neon colors yeah we wanted sharp
tonal clashes we talked about temple of
doom all the time how you know it would
go from you know you'd have gore
juxtaposed with you know silly comedy
and romance that's what we were trying
to do with season three and then season
four it was let's go nightmare in elm
street let's go let's go hell raiser and
a lot of that started with well coming
up with zach and high school you're
talking about how horrible high school
was and you see this there's a shift at
the end of three where it does get sad
and it does get darker and so we sort of
went with that and ran with it and and
you've gotta and you have to we try to
season the season go well let's not
ignore the events that happened
previously yeah you feel that impact
really especially in max's arc yeah i
mean it really resonates that's what we
want to do and just go and we we did try
to do it season two as well which is
something traumatic happened to these
characters so let's let's go with that
and let's see how they actually respond
to it and how would someone respond to
something this traumatic in in real life
they wouldn't be able to just shake it
off and go about their normal lives yeah
and that's beautiful you could do that
in this format versus like regular
episodic tv exactly now you say you kind
of dovetailed that emotional thing from
three to four we're in four and now
going to five and i believe that you
said that you had the complete story arc
was planned out from the beginning is
that true
i mean roughly i mean the show evolves
right so
you discover things like i mean it's not
it's not i mean there's a rough map but
it's just constantly changing i mean the
perfect example of that is steve like
steve you know played by beautifully by
joke gary he wasn't supposed to be here
uh uh here he shouldn't be in season
four he shouldn't be a lead in season
four so that he he shouldn't be a good
guy right so a lot of that you're
discovering as you're going so you're
learning what works what doesn't work
and that's what i do love about
television is that you're finding it the
cast is impacting where you're taking
the narrative the other writers who you
work with are impacting it so the other
directors who are working on the show
it's just living thing so it's changed
yeah it's beautiful when you see steve
in the season one you're like oh that
guy's gonna get killed off it's so
wonderfully surprising oh was the plan
well i don't know if was he supposed to
die no
no
okay no yeah i don't remember you
supposed to die in the finale i thought
it was because i thought originally it
was it was
you know because there's that scene
where really which is the beginning of
his turn which is when he comes back
in the end and he comes and ends up
fighting the demogorgon with jonathan
enanteen and originally that was gonna
be
um jonathan's dad lonnie
so it just which is i i it's hard to
even even imagine what that would have
looked like i don't remember that steve
was going to i'm pretty sure he was
going to die earlier it's been a while
but anyway that's what i'm saying is it
does evolve it evolves so
it's not like we're making it all up as
we go along but the characters and the
actors and everyone who works on the
show
informs what we're doing yeah and so
about so maybe this did you have the
vechna henry one twist in mind from the
beginning how did how did you set that
up so for so many seasons and yet
we we didn't get we didn't catch on
because it was really a surprise oh
that's great when we originally pitched
the show to netflix we really just had
that first season planned out and but i
remember
part the way through writing season one
netflix said hey can you guys just walk
us through the mythology of the show
and so we sat down with our writers and
we spent a couple weeks just going okay
what is the upside down and how how did
it come to be and
what monsters are in there and all of
this in that document it's about a
20-page document and that really has a
most of what we're talking about now it
doesn't have of course it wasn't like
there's gonna be a twist in season four
it didn't it wasn't that detailed but
the big beats there and there's still
stuff
and we hint about it in this season we
start getting into a little bit about
the upside down but we don't answer it
yet so but we have those answers so the
last sort of remaining questions that
are answered in that document we've
punted a couple of those to have some
big reveals in season five and that's
really gonna affect what season five is
about uh stranger things has a lot of
pretty scary monsters but we all know
that the worst monsters
for me especially when i'm watching it
the worst monsters are the bullies and
the jocks did you intend on that
well i think you know when we developed
this show and came up with it we were
really inspired by stephen king and in
his work which is something we haven't
been shy about and i think you know
what's really something that really is
important to his work is that yes a lot
of times there are these supernatural
monsters but really a lot of the horror
comes from
the humans in the story in in the
darkness within all of us and so every
season we really do want to have that to
play a major role and this season really
is no different and like specifically
like the jocks i think we were
interested in you know we've had some
bad boy characters we had um we had
billy you know obviously in season
season two and three and then season one
we kind of had these straight you know
typical middle school bullies but we
wanted to explore someone who
had this never occurred would have
probably led
a really good life like like someone who
was very popular who had a sort of
self-righteous streak in him who was
viewed by the community as as
completely virtuous and then this thing
happens which is you know the death of
his girlfriend
and it's just it spins him and all of
this stuff that is inside of him that
probably would have never been unlocked
had that not occurred
um comes spilling out so um that was for
us an interesting character to explore
and also the and also the idea of a lot
of times we introduce a new character to
this world and they see this these
extraordinary supernatural things and
they react to it i mean sometimes in
fear and wonder but they're able mostly
to sort of overcome that and what we
wanted to explore also was well what if
a character sees this and he cracks a
little bit yeah because it's hard
how would one react to seeing something
so
outside of what we think reality is yeah
so we wanted to explore that a lot
that's really interesting because you
don't normally see that you always see
these teenagers like yeah i'm okay let
let's save the world and like a lot of
the characters do step up and nuanced
ways um but yeah it's really interesting
to explore that we have a lot to look
forward to but thank you for gifting us
volume one because it is truly fantastic
thank you thank you so much for being
here today
thank you so much thank you yeah thank
you
next i sit down with winona ryder and
david harbour let's get back in the ussr
yeah
adulting is hard especially in hawkins
to tell us more about that please
welcome david harbour who plays hopper
hawkins police chief back from the dead
and winona writer who plays everyone's
favorite hawkits mom joyce byers
david you filmed some scenes in the ussr
definitely without love there were a lot
of brutal scenes in this season how how
did produce the film i mean some of them
were very pleasant on a sound stage in
atlanta and some of them were in the
snows of lithuania
we shot in a
real prison outside of uh
right in vilnius lithuania so the snow
and the craziness i mean i guess the
toughest stuff was
at one point
hopper abandons his shoes
as he escapes and so for a lot of it i'm
running
shoeless
through the snows of lithuania and there
were a lot of takes where you could see
my feet so we had to do that and it's
really not pleasant
for your uh bare feet to be on snow for
a long period of time so so i found my
inner wolf my inner russian bear okay
i'm gonna watch the episodes with that
in mind you're channeling that it's kind
of a brutal season i mean it was brutal
like uh physically in that way and it
was also kind of brutal emotionally like
hopper goes to a darker place i think
than we've ever seen him certainly in
the prison when we figure out exactly
what happened to sarah and to
you know in his life before that it was
this kind of very dark still
moment of hopelessness for him
but then he is reinvigorated when
you know two two of his friends come to
russia to help him out which is an epic
journey i don't know do you know what
could motivate joyce to do something
that impetuous
uh just
oh yeah
i mean a topper
and then like you know when i say
he is
like
family
it like literally they they are like
family
and
there's no way
she couldn't have gone
joyce where you going the bank i'm gonna
get enzo his damn money
and we are getting hopper back
okay
so i to me it was just like it made
absolute sense yeah and and for hopper i
mean you survived torture you survive
broken bones the soviet prison camp like
is the same thing keeping you going with
joyce
i think that you know i mean one of the
great things about this relationship one
of the things i find very gratified and
i think is really cool is that it's so
understated in the first season i mean i
think that
they
talk briefly about knowing each other in
high school
he's actually kind of like not the best
to her in the beginning of the first
season um kind of gross to be on her
side but
clearly you can feel and i think part of
it was just you know winona and my what
we chose to highlight in their
relationship but certainly like there
was a beautiful scene that i remember in
season two when
they're talking about
just like things getting easier and like
smoking a cigarette at this kitchen
table that there's just so much depth to
the
to the relationship a lot of history
yeah that scene and i think one of the
beautiful things is that they've known
each other when they were kids like
it's fun that the show's about kids but
you have these characters that knew each
other when they were
13 14
and then they split off and he went and
had an entire other life and and then
you have actors who were
the kids
during the time it's set in yeah exactly
well yeah do you have a sense of
nostalgia when you're in the the makeup
the hair the the because you know i'm a
kid of the 80s too like i remember that
as a tiny tiny kid i mean i have a
natural sort of nostalgia because i
i mean what years beetlejuice come out
87 87 i think yeah so i'm like literally
i probably would have gone to the movie
theater i wouldn't have got hopper
wouldn't have gone well but maybe 11
would have like begged him to take her
to the theater because she wanted to see
the new tim burton movie
i have a big obsession with beetlejuice
for sure when i was a kid i definitely i
think maybe 11 will watch like pee-wee
her favorite playhouse in next season
right because that was tim's first movie
[Laughter]
are the dumpers around because i want
that impression in season five i do want
to talk a little bit about the satanic
panic now we're talking about like
flashbacks do you remember the satanic
panic of the 80s i do okay tell me about
that
it was crazy
i mean
i really do remember this i remember
album the censorship the um
yeah
do you remember tom hanks first movie i
mean i remember being in love with tom
hanks the man with one red shoe no this
is before this i think it's an after
school special about dungeons and
dragons
oh wait a minute it's the best it's the
best it's like a tv movie
tom hanks is like on a dnd he's like a
dungeons and dragons dungeon master with
his friends it was about how if you
played d d it was clearly a very
christian
like organization it was saying d is the
devil and it's going to possess you and
make you insane and tom hanks is
wonderful in it of course michael landon
probably produced
oh touched by an angel
big hair big heart i'm not going to let
us go because uh david i need i need to
know both of you what are you
particularly geeking out over what are
you particularly excited to about i'm
talking to you because we just talked
about world of warcraft so i just need
to get that a little bit on tape about
what we're going to do the most
embarrassing thing is what is it in my
existence
right so in 2005 yeah there i played the
the [ __ ] out of this game
ruined my life
for like a year i mean i was like out of
my mind
yeah i was wildly addicted to this video
what character you play uh what was it i
was a night elf warrior uh called norad
and he was
he was a he was like you know second
tank of my uh my whole guild oh so
you're a raider oh yeah oh yeah i was
like full on and it's so funny because i
like i've also played the sims you ever
played oh yeah so i cheated all the time
you could be an actor on the sims you
can
progress in your career but what you
have to do is you have to like work on
things you have to work on your speech
and on your body right oh my god and i
remember but i remember my avatar
got to a certain level in his career and
he
i kept trying to get him to work on him
wait tables
no he was like a supporting player but
he i want him to work on his speech in
his body and all he wanted to do was sit
around and play video games and i kept
being like you know and then i was like
whoa
at this vortex moment where i saw
my life
you know before my an actor playing that
game
could really mess with your head that's
what it did
and that's why my life was ruined well
you're doing pretty well for yourself it
came back yeah you came back come back
you're the tyson fury of acting and your
avatar's always waiting for you if you
want to rio
oh my god winona is there anything
particularly that you're into it doesn't
need to be video games cooking like your
your pets like is there anything you're
pretty excited about yeah
i mean i'm just a huge
movie fan
of
like
my dream when i was a kid
was to there was this theater in my town
that was an old theater and i wanted to
like my fantasy was like
when i grew up to like rip out all the
seats put like a bed like a tub
and like a bike to exercise and just 24
7 watch movies
and never leave yo netflix
reality show all you need to do is buy a
theater and a bathtub and a bed and have
a winona ryder watch movies
24 7 for her whole life and i will watch
that show
i will watch my fans the [ __ ] out of
that show
all right you heard it here we noticed
when a movie theater picked up on
netflix next season anyway well thank
you so much for being here it's been
such a pleasure getting to know you i
admire your work so much both of you
bring so much gravity and humor and
heart to the screen and i cannot wait to
see where your characters go from here
thanks a lot thank you
thank you
can you guess who's next by reading my
mind
i bet she could that's right we've got
the lovely millie bobby brown
[Music]
eleven starts off in lenora
california
she starts off in school
she's very much
dealing with the loss of hopper or as
she thinks
and she's also dealing with
the regular life of being at school
which is uh you know she's quite she's
bullied um
and she's just trying to understand how
to be a normal person you know she she
grew up in a laboratory and she grew up
very sheltered and told what to do holy
[ __ ] what the hell was that i'm
definitely really excited about the fans
seeing eleven without powers and her
struggle and the frustration
of wanting to
you know use them you know because she's
so used to using them they're nobodies
and you're a superhero
[Music]
not anymore
the fourth season i really appreciate
the duffers taking away her her main
ability um her most favorite thing of
all her most
valued and uh
dependent thing that she has in her life
is our superpowers and taking that away
where does that leave us um and and who
am i really so it was really
uh great having the first you know six
episodes to really be able to deep dive
into her emotional well-being instead of
just her um extraterrestrial kind of
being and seeing the real relationship
struggles of mike and eleven and putting
um some some strain and some tension on
that um instead of it always being like
happy daisies you know are your friends
gonna meet us there friends with friends
you know stacy and angela
angela you'll meet them i promise just
not today i want today
to be about me and you i think there's a
sense of embarrassment um you know and
humility um
she wants to tell him everything's fine
and i think there's a sense of fomo you
know she wants to be in hawkins she
wants to be with her friends and i feel
like she's just trying to let mike know
everything's fine i'm fine here i'm
actually having way more fun than you
are and really the the bottom line is
she's not she's struggling um and she's
hiding that from him she knows that she
has to
deal with those bullies and that alone
because
no one will truly understand what like
it's what it's like to be that different
um you know she's not just like a nerd
she's
she's
one in a million you know she's not
really no one like her and um
i think that the duff has made a great
decision in splitting us apart i think
showing a different 1980s location um
you know as such as california it's such
a different vibe than indiana in the 80s
knowing and seeing it on set it's such a
different vibe
honestly finn said it the other day it
does feel like we're filming a
completely different show
i think the distance actually
creates some development
and growth between everyone um but you
know in true stranger things style um we
always come back together and it always
it always ends up in the upside down
[Music]
it's the older teens of stranger things
you really get the show rolling because
they are the ones with the driver's
licenses with me now are joe quinn
joining the cast this year as eddie
munson president of hellfire and
perpetual hawk and senior
maya hogg who's left her scooper behind
to rewind at the video store as robin
buckley and joe kiri who plays the
lovable slacker slash everyone's
favorite babysitter steve harrington hi
y'all hey there always the babysitter
always the goddamn babysitter it is time
to talk about friendship in the time of
vechna joe and maya your characters are
both looking for love this season it's
kind of
cute but sad um can you talk a little
bit about your fun dynamic as you
support each other through this quest oh
that was ah so fun i don't know it was
just like it's like my favorite part of
the season it's great it's just a really
fun storyline to have kind of
always happening underneath all this
crazy supernatural stuff yeah it feels
like it really is
like
the it roots our storyline a really nice
way them i think my favorite scene to
shoot the whole series was that kind of
almost wonder we did in the video store
totally or we're like talking and videos
are falling down and like
and reorganizing things and like that
was i i love that stuff and getting to
do that in the beginning before we go on
to film the rest of the season
exactly what you were saying sort of set
in like a
i don't know like what the what the
feeling was on the inside
and the tone for shooting too yeah you
know like
the the
vibe on set was was very very
positive and reassuring and yeah easy
and it was like a place to try different
things and yeah those scenes in a lot of
ways it's like with this show there's so
much supernatural stuff going on you
generally
you know
the setup of the show is where you kind
of have more these kind of dialogue
driven scenes and those are generally
the ones that are
i find the most fun to work on yeah the
rapport that you guys have is really
genuine and you just kind of see you
guys riff on something like forever
i know i remember us joking about when
this season started that we were like
can we just have a year one season where
nothing happens yeah it's just like we
just do high school video store normal
like let me get the girls like let's
just and then next season like
everything can happen but like let's
just live and just one more win
joe your character eddie was an
immediate fan favorite these are not
interests that necessarily intersect you
personally you're not a metal head
you're not a d d nerd
not currently no not currently not yet
is there a possibility that you could be
converted to the nerd side i'm open to
anything wow okay you heard it here on
geek
[Laughter]
do you have any 80s tropes that you drew
from i guess well it's kind of obvious
but spinal tap really i think kind of
just in terms of like how uh being a
metalhead isn't a part-time gig it's
you've got to take it pretty seriously
totally um i guess kind of like
thematically like in the show i think
there's a lot of john carpenter stuff in
there i think
and scooby-doo as well in our um scooby
doo i think if spielberg and john
carpenter directed a scooby-doo film wow
that would be amazing yeah well we're in
it
you're totally right it's like
the that's what it is the strong
and different characterizations of each
character it's very scooby-doo and very
d yeah you know everybody has their
their sort of specialty and skill and
mindset and they do a good job of making
you know setting that up definitely fred
from scooby-doo
in episode six our teens head out on
lovers lake where jack patrick has just
been taken by vechna steve as former
swimming captain volunteers to head
underwater to see if a rift has opened
at the bottom of the lake
there he goes
[Music]
i forgot how amazing
this has my favorite moment of years in
it i think
i remember you doing all the practical
work of course yeah remember people
calling you a rock star yes i i remember
nimrod saying yeah
that's not looking good
so joe can you talk to us a little bit
about filming that scene was it in a
tank like it looked yeah it seems like
you were underwater a long time yeah it
was like a studio like probably the size
of
it was in a big convention center in
atlanta by the airport and they built a
tank that was probably
um how big do you think it was guys like
40
feet it was a big circle 45 it's
probably a few gallons i think yeah a
few gallons
16 feet down or something but um
so they had this scaffolding rig and
then obviously a set at the bottom and i
mean it was incredible yeah shooting we
all shot on the stage and it was just
getting to do that sort of stuff is like
true
movie magic sort of stuff so did you
know that you were going to be a swimmer
because
it would be awkward if you didn't know
how to swim
before the first season they had told me
i was going to be a swimmer and in the
script they're like yeah you're going to
be a swimmer it's going to be like some
swim meet you're going to be like in a
speedo you know it's the 80s it's like
oh my god i have to like get in shape
and did all these swimming lessons and
you know like i was paying for all this
stuff and then we i showed up and
they're like oh no yeah we cut that we
couldn't get the jet we couldn't get the
pool couldn't get a pool so that was all
cut and then but they wrote this back in
you know later so it all kind of worked
i could swim beforehand though okay i
could i can't swim for the record which
is good
of course there's more stranger things
right around the corner when volume 2
drops on july 1st thank you for coming
right side up to join me here i really
appreciate this conversation of course
thank you sadly the star court mall was
burnt to a crisp in season three the
upside of no longer having a food court
where you can get terrible pretzels
the hawkins teens are forced to hang out
in our studio
please welcome some familiar faces from
our hawkins crew finn wolfhart who plays
mike wheeler who's about to get his
spring break ruined
gayton moderazo playing everyone's
favorite goofy nerd dunstan henderson
priya ferguson who plays the ever
resourceful erica sinclair sadie sink
who plays a grieving emotionally closed
off max mayfield and caleb mclaughlin
playing a too cool for his normal crew
lucas sinclair
so last season ended on a cliffhanger
and season four started in chaos right
at the bottom finn what was it like to
be split up from your crew your best
friend your girlfriend elle i mean mike
was separated from elle before but it
was a little bit different how how was
your journey this season yeah it starts
out and mike's kind of like
i think pretty excited to go and visit
his girlfriend his best friend he's kind
of a little more disconnected from will
and
kind of starting to find his own way as
well in
high school he doesn't really feel
probably as
doesn't feel as like separated from from
people so he's finally finding his kind
of friend group pretty yeah it's a
pretty chaotic season i would say
it was like
so fun and and like different and also
pretty amazing too to like start the
season off with like caleb and sadie and
uh gayton because
we rarely get to be in like scenes
together nowadays because there's so
many story lines happening and whenever
we get to like go back to the kind of
the basics and be able to like have like
scenes all together that aren't so crazy
and
i don't know it's really really fun yeah
it was a really fun time jump between
seasons and
max is in a much different place this
season sadie can you talk about why
yeah i mean she's obviously dealing with
the grief and guilt surrounding billy's
death
her living situation has changed so
things are just kind of gone downhill
and that's kind of where we start out
with her and then obviously things get
much much worse
yes we're going to have to get into that
because it's a whole deal
gayten dustin seems to really step up to
be more of a leader character this
season how does that feel did it feel
good i think it's cool i think uh it's
definitely a goal of his to try and feel
a little bit more confident going into
into high school i think he's kind of
put a little bit more emphasis on on
on his his look and uh and the group he
sees that lucas is is becoming more
confident and doing some great stuff and
finding himself and i think in a way
that
that
hurts a man motivates him uh but yeah i
think uh it's just a general
a confident search uh maybe motivated by
his friendship with with steve but yeah
yeah it's it's fun to play it really is
cool to start out that way the d and d
basketball montage it was so epic i
can't believe it and i would love to
show you a clip let's take a look
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
are you kidding me no yeah first time is
it as epic as you thought it was going
to be yes more so sick yeah music is
awesome yeah
caleb
how do you relate to lucas's journey
trying to figure out who he is and where
he belongs you are really torn in two
different directions this season right
yeah um i i understand where lucas is in
his life at the time because he's young
he's a teenager and kind of go through
this like
time where you're like okay who am i
what do i like where where do i really
fit in you know the the spared or the
world speaks to you
and you know i mean of course we're
probably not gonna lucas is not saying
that but i feel like he probably had a
moment where it was just like
who am i like let me go figure it out
and you know he has his friends there
but
he needed to you know adventure out to
figure out who he was first before he
can like appreciate his love that he had
for his friends and the nerd that he is
yeah so
well it's not it's not unfounded i mean
you are being torn into
and they don't show up for you so it's a
little bit frustrating right i
understand why they're upset because
they're like no this is how you always
been this is who you are like what are
you doing but you know you never realize
or you never appreciate things unless
you don't have it anymore you know until
you don't have it anymore so i felt when
lucas didn't have that friendship or
like the realness of being with his
friends from you know the beginning he
was like okay i know who i am he just
needed to step out of the box real quick
before he realized well lucas is chasing
his hoop dreams erica takes her seat at
the table and joins the dnd campaign
priya can you talk about how it felt for
erica to sort of replace her brother
this season in the crew i definitely
feel like it was a leadership moment for
erica it was her proving to
um the hellfire club that she is a
leader and she's a problem solver and i
feel like erica has always been a leader
in the past seasons even with the cape
how she came in with the cave that was a
um
very
it was a it was her being a leader and
stepping in for her brother to help out
the hellfire club and her friends so
that's how i feel
things could not be stranger for max
this season
it is a lot sadie your character
has been tormented in the present by the
past we talked a little bit about max's
rough start this season
why do you think vekna targeted her of
everybody well i mean you kind of learn
in the season that he targets
people that are in a real place
um
and max is obviously one of those people
um just with everything with billy
um
so yeah she was kind of like the perfect
target but i think she's a little bit
i guess stronger than the others through
the help of her friends and everything
absolutely so she had an advantage well
max trapped in the mind later is the
first glimpse that we get into vecna's
ultimate plan we have a clip so let's
take a look
we're clips
[Music]
is
again
sadie wow that was a lot can you talk
about filming that escape scene it was
so intense yeah that was shot over
i don't know how many i think it might
have been a week that we spent on that
or like four days i guess
um a lot of time spent in the harness i
guess um
yeah it was pretty intense and like all
the like
vines and stuff like obvio like none of
that's there we did get really lucky
this year because vecna was pretty much
fully practical effects um which kind of
you know made it easier for me so i'm
not like staring at a man in a green
suit
um
but yeah i was it was pretty intense
definitely had some got a little scraped
up but it was really really fun um can
we touch upon the reveal of vekno one
henry did that blow your minds like it
did the audience yeah that's like an
amazing twist jamie's like unbelievable
and he had to i mean i only met him a
few times but from what i could hear i
mean how long was he had to probably if
it was like a 7 a.m crew call
he would have to come in at
1am what the morning before
while they put the makeup on him as
becna and he like never complained he
never like he's so patient i ran into
him once throughout the entirety of
filming and it was when we were doing 3d
scans to touch on becna i thought it was
really cool to um see the evil of
hawkins kind of reveal itself i thought
that was really cool you know
finn mike
doesn't quite get the spring break he
hoped for when he he imagined in
california uh how fun was it to film all
the action stuff that you got to do this
season
uh really fun and also like
incredibly difficult and we basically
filmed a movie within a movie like we
filmed like
we filmed a different movie kind of uh
and uh we shot like a stoner
thriller
comedy kind of while they shot like a
really like a drama-filled sci-fi like
harold kumar
yeah exactly and so it was like a really
different vibe and i think like the
duffer brothers were very excited kind
of to have like a different
i don't know uh
a different change of pace i think they
had also like a new crew and stuff and
those are insanely fun i mean we did
this one take uh action scene it's like
the shootout
um yeah and
that was like a day of rehearsal and
then um yeah it was
crazy stay here
we did it i mean we were all like by the
end of it we were all bruised and like
did you get it like on the ground like
you know so uh it was really fun but uh
yeah also
yeah just like tiring as well well we
actually sat down with director sean
levy to talk about shooting that scene
let's take a look
hey there felicia sean levy here i am
super bummed that i can't be with you
doing geeked week all together uh but
very much there in spirit i'm here in
budapest shooting my next project but
completely excited to nerd out alongside
finn and all the rest of the gang who
were a part of this uh epic shootout
warner which was both the most
challenging piece of directing and
ultimately one of the most gratifying
pieces of directing i've ever done the
writing that matt and ross do
it tells me what they want on screen and
so i'm reading episode four i come to
the shootout sequence and it just felt
like
oh this should feel kinetic and this
should feel
real time and viscerally connected to
the characters who were suddenly caught
in the middle of this bad luck that was
fast and i read the scene a few times i
called matt and ross and i was like guys
i'm feeling warner am i crazy or am i
feeling wonder they're like hell yes
we've never done kind of an action
runner with gun play uh and so it was
gonna be hard it was gonna be near
impossible but i was so inspired by this
feeling that i had to try on a movie you
take months you literally take months of
computer pre-visualizations and
storyboarding and rehearsals and
re-choreography it's stranger things we
are at the end of the day we're a huge
tv show but we're a tv series so there
was no time for previz no time for
storyboards and we had to essentially
choreograph and prep that shootout while
we were shooting other scenes every day
so
it involved
one choreography session where it was
myself and my cinematographer and my ad
and the stunt coordinator and we just
kind of read the scene in the house and
it was a lot of like well what if they
come through this window well what if as
we're running this way there's another
gunman over here and it was a lot of
what if and we started acting out the
wood and then the camera sees you
you want to look back
we gotta go
crash
go go the only way i know how to direct
is to kind of viscerally give the actors
a sense of the scene and so for this i
was literally acting out every role of
me playing
will byers and jonathan and mike
i do believe that the best way to feed
my actors energy is by giving them
energy
the whole challenge with a oner is it
requires perfect synchronicity between
actor action
stunt action and camera action so every
pan every tilt every move of the actor
it needs to be in unison so that you're
seeing the event you want at the exact
moment that you want it so if one of
those three things is a little early or
a little late cut go again cut go again
so it just takes one mistake to make the
one or unusable stay there
everybody needed to do their jobs at a
high high level of near perfection and
ultimately that's a daunting challenge
but an incredibly satisfying piece of
filmmaking as a result
this has been a lot of fun breaking down
the episode four shootout warner with
all of you cannot wait for you to see
what else we have in store for you and
stranger things for it's a doozy
[Music]
and that's our show i am tempted to end
this episode of unlocked with a crazy
twist that would make the duffer
brothers proud
or you know like a horrible pun but i'm
gonna settle for this unlocked will be
back after the second and final volume
of season four drops on july 1st oh and
don't go away we're about to see the
hellfire club engage in an epic d battle
right here on geek week see you
then it is over 11.
you have freed me
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't stop this now
[Music]
my name is uh children munoz i'm an
illustrator and storyteller from
guayaquil ecuador and i get to draw for
a living
you know everybody gets their influences
as they grow up for me when i went to
school i really latched on to people
like ub iworks and ozamo dazuka so my
two biggest influence is a combination
of japanese pop culture and classic
american rubber hose cartoons
for the stranger things piece
specifically
i originally titled the piece i am the
monster i even essentially fused the
character of 11 and the demogorgon
together
being an artist sometimes especially
like working in different industries
it can sometimes feel like a rat race
the reminder i always tell myself is
just focus on my voice what i would like
to see him put out there in the world
[Music]
three two one milly
you me yes
[Music]
are you ready i am
i'm so
[Music]
good
excited
all right let's talk let's do it let's
do it
will is kind of a third wheel this
season between mike and elle especially
when mike
comes to visit l
l this season um had a pretty big
character arc um she's been through a
lot you know she is pretty severely
bullied when we find her um which was
really sad we just find ellen will
they're living together in california
and they look out for each other yeah
and me and millie kind of had a week
where it was just us filming in the
school and it was definitely one of my
favorite weeks yeah
it was so fun yeah it was so much fun
how long does it take to get rid it
takes to get uh
i think it takes about
i'd say an hour
i think millie is one of the longest
getting ready just because of her wigs
it takes about an hour to do my old wig
my makeup isn't that crazy at all um the
most i have is a bit of mascara and some
blush
what was your favorite moment this
season i think my fit i think this
season was very split up by like the
locations we filmed at and i think my
favorite locations were at either the
school or honestly this week at the
roller rink has been a blast every day
at lunch millie connects her phone and
we just
skater
we just skate around the ring and it's
it's a lot of fun right yeah i think
personally my favorite like moment on
set is anything in new mexico like i
really enjoy mexico has been a blast i
really enjoyed atlanta and i actually
loved working with matthew modine should
we recreate the scene where you picked
me up
although i have gone a bit bigger now
you are a bit bigger
also being in new mexico has been like
so fun for me yeah just a change of
scenery i didn't know what to expect i
was like we're going kind of in the
middle of nowhere like this is a new
group new crew
and now looking back it's like one of my
favorite like things i've ever done and
we've had a blast and it's been the best
proof
i would describe how to look well i mean
when we find her she is in like a
flannel she's probably borrowing will's
clothes
it is very sad and it's meant to be sad
you know yeah um and she's in half you
know beautiful pink little floral like
floral with those white jeans which
feels very like it feels very feminine
and kind of heroic
it's a very heroic look i like that
all right three two one ready oh we're
just saying the version yeah
three two one eduardo oh really what
eduardo that was one day no he does
laugh a lot hold on your butt bro
chachos
edwardo was one day where we couldn't
stop laughing but usually i feel like
it's i feel like it is us and it also
can be charlie on like some days like he
just won't stop i think eduardo is just
a big laugh
most likely to go on love island
three two one you
i love honestly like our favorite show
this is our favorite show it kind of got
us through season
[Music]
who is most likely come here who's most
likely okay who is who's most likely
who's most likely to who is the most
shut up who is most likely oh who is
most likely
to
[Laughter]
who is most likely
okay who is most likely who's most
likely to go off script three two one
right no not his funeral screw his
funeral
if anyone asks where i am i've left the
country
no i know this one you have to know this
one three two one charlie
guys shut up
oh three two three three two one
oh that's true
[Music]
you're not including me in that
are you actually kidding i feel fine me
just me what do you mean we're both good
at that i feel like we're both very
close to the crew yeah both of us not
just you like we are like no no you said
who's the favorite and i know that i'm
the crew's favorite
amy who's your favorite out of me and
millie can i answer that at wraps no you
can answer that now can i answer that
rap who do you think is cruz favorite
past number yeah yeah
what they do say it all the time am i
not your favorite out of the
cast you're my favorite okay so don't
cut that out i need that for milly
they say it all the time
sunglasses yesterday okay well i have
gifts for you today then maybe i won't
be giving you anymore i'll keep it for
my
myself
he's stuck i'm done with this interview
ridiculous
okay well who's uh most likely to get
mad because they're not the favorite
three two one
sniffer schnapp who is the best who's
best me or you me and millie
we are united yeah we are united we're
best friends yeah i think it's like the
best when you get to walk with your best
friends yeah it's awesome and i always
love working with millie and this season
i've gone to work with her probably the
most out of any other season
yeah we've had discussions together this
season and it was just such a blast like
actually getting to act off of her and
she is incredible and i had the best
time with her
and i'm so lucky to get to work i'm so
lucky
[Music]
[Music]
to hear that
something is
coming something hungry for blood the
democore
fireball him
fireball
[Music]
will
are you here
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
aah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys
well are you okay
[Music]
[Music]
you got the
[Music]
how many children are you friends with
[Music]
something i wanted to talk to you both
about
i know this is a difficult conversation
but i care about you both very much
and i know that you care about each
other very much and that's why it's
important that we set these boundaries
moving forward so we can build an
environment
where we all feel
comfortable
trusted
and open
to sharing our feelings
feelings
jesus
the truth is
for so long i'd forgotten what those
even were i've been stuck in one place
and then
i left some eggos out in the woods and
you came into my life and
for the first time
in a long time
i started to feel things again
i started to feel happy
but lately
i guess i've been feeling
distant from you
like you're
you're pulling away from me or something
but i know you're getting older
growing
changing
and i guess
if i'm being really honest
that's what scares me
i don't want things to change
[Music]
but i know that's naive
it's just
not how life works
it's moving
always moving whether you like it or not
so you know what
keep on growing up kid
don't let me stop you
make mistakes
learn from them
and when life hurts you
because it will
remember the hurt
but please
if you don't mind
for the sake of your poor old dad
keep the door open
three inches
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
want even more stranger things you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
to doom the official netflix site to
help find and fuel your fandom from
behind the scenes photos to red carpet
coverage to 80s hairstyle secrets from
set dive deeper into the upside down on
netflix.com
[Music]
[Music]
on behalf of netflix geek welcome all
humans dwarves and halflings especially
you creatures at home who are stranger
things super fans like me
you're in for a special geeked week
treat today i'm sitting down with the
hellfire club themselves for a one of a
kind dungeons and dragons adventure i'm
your host and dungeon master b dave
walters and the adventurer is joining me
on today's quest none other than finn
wolfhard priya ferguson gayden
monterrazzo and joe quinn
the hooded cultists chant
hail
lord
vechna
that was dead i just killed my cat no it
was thought my friend so it was thought
but vecna lived
[Music]
today was supposed to be a good day
after years of grand adventuring you're
returning home to hawks end
each of you has made your way through
the world carving your legend into
history
goblins giants ogres trolls dragons all
manner of monsters have fallen before
you
again and again you've won
cheating death itself
and today
death has come to collect
okay our heroes
pardon me belching
joe keary
chad handstand
and lady applejack
you see home in the distance
hawk's end is a small beautiful town it
sits on a little island in the middle of
the river as the water flows around it
on all sides creating kind of a natural
boundary there's only two ways in a
bridge to the north and a bridge to the
south surrounded on all sides by
luscious forest
as you see home in the distance you can
already catch the smell of baking bread
wafting on the wind you hear children
laughing off in the distance and can see
the smokestacks rising out of familiar
sights of home
just north of hawke's end there's a
ranger station a guard post that you
have to check in as you four heroes come
walking up
what would you like to do
oh fun
whoever would like to you all the four
of you are walking down the road i'm
assuming we have like passports and
stuff to get on through so i guess we're
gonna go to the ranger station and uh
uh i don't really seem to have a lot of
charisma here i'm gonna be like can i
get through
you know uh important question here what
does pardon me belching look like who is
he uh pardon me belcham he's a smelly
dude i mean he has to kind of like he it
wasn't his given name but like he came
up with it later in life and thought
that it would be a good thing to like
just set the boundaries of what
interacting with him might be like
um so smelly dude he's not the not the
brightest um at least people around him
don't think he is and he's kind of
accepted that throughout most of his
days but uh he enjoys an adventure he
enjoys
a good bar fight i'd say and um he
above all else enjoys family and you're
a dwarven grave cleric yeah so he's
a morbid one
would say it's a sense of humor some
would say it's just weird
as you call out down the road from
inside the booth all of you here
ah
you for back again
and a head
leans out a familiar head that you've
all seen
of an unpleasant bug bear named gloom
bug bear is kind of a deceptive title
they actually look more like large um
predatory cat people similar to a tabaxi
like you but honestly the comparison
would be a little offensive and you and
gloom have never really gotten along
because of this
he has black hair that is knotted and
kinked and has twigs and muck in it
because he's never overly concerned with
his appearance
thought you all were off becoming
legends
you know i hear the stories all the time
of oh chad handstand held a handstand
whatever who cares
why are you back
hungry
tired tired supplies do we need supplies
you know important question joe kerry
what does joe carry the
gloom stalker ranger look like
5 11
brown eyes
sunny disposition
great chat
wicked sense of humour although
apparently he's got no charisma or
intelligence which is kind of
really interesting
you speak a different language kind of
thing now you're a cat person so what
does your fur look like
what would joe kiri's phone look like
just perfect
yeah it's just it just looks just right
what color what color it's kind of brown
and kind of like mousy right but kind of
like oily but it kind of not too oily it
kind of just it just looks nice
and what does lady applejack look like
she's an ill
assassin rogue yes the most dangerous
yeah the most
dangerous
it says dark elf
large
apple jacket
is sneaky
perfect yes i think i think she's
killing it actually because she doesn't
want to give too much away exactly you
said you'll find out she doesn't like it
last but certainly not least chad
handstand what does he look like well he
uh
you know uh he's not he's not the most
strong guy in the world but he is uh you
know he's got some
he's he's pretty uh he's pretty big yeah
no um he he's but he's like he's kind of
like the skinny strong you know he's not
like super maxed out or anything but
he's like
he's like a robert pattinson kind of
type but like in that kind of way you
know like a scrawny yet strong now
you're a human paladin but you
while you what you were lacking in the
charisma okay joe yes
and chad took all of it
yeah beautiful the wind is always
blowing perfectly in his hair the sun is
always hitting him just right must be
nice
he got the name chad handstand though
because you know he was like he was at a
funeral and everyone was crying and to
cheer everyone up he said watch this and
in hindsight it might have made
everything up yeah inappropriate might
have made everything about him but he
still did the handstand and from that
point on
he was known as chad hansen did it kill
do people like it uh well technically it
killed it wasn't a funeral but um
no it didn't kill no one liked it but he
kept that um
and from that moment on he kind of
he just became so he thought this went
terribly
i'm gonna keep doing this he doesn't
really know he doesn't he doesn't he
can't read people as well but that makes
him very confident oh cool uh
gloom still hasn't forgiven you for
doing a handstand at his grandmother's
funeral so yeah
comes out of the road and he stands
nearly seven foot tall towering he's the
big guy
yeah
i hate to admit it but it's probably
good that you're here
there's been some
difficulties as of late
you know you probably should just make
your way into town i guess
astara she's at city hall she'll explain
it all to you
just
do what you're gonna do and get out of
here soon the town's better off without
you
this guy i thought he needed us okay i
don't i'm fine
so you've got to go and see a star
you all uh you all know astara uh she is
in elf she has been in charge all of
your lives all the way back when your
grandparents were children because elves
are very long-lived okay
yeah whatever and gloom goes back into
his shack and he slams the doorbell
this is a problem
what you got a problem
i think he likes i can't no no no no
yeah i'm not jealous yeah i don't care
if that's what you think it's not bad
he's kind of jay he wants to be a part
of the group no like you guys like went
to do your thing some of us had a duty
to home and stayed here to keep track
you wonder why you're by yourself it's
just like what are you doing
i mean that's unnecessary okay joe like
i mean you just got back i
like being by myself yeah
[Laughter]
slams the door again and ahead of you
stands the bridge to cross over into
hawke's end okay
so we should we should probably cross
over that bridge let's go let's cross
over there let's go find astara really
quickly because
i'm not really feeling this right now
i'm tired i know it's ready yeah
is you guys come walking in again you
all have been
all over the world by now but there's
nowhere like home as you come back again
uh there's a
fresh apple pie sitting on the
windowsill um children running around
have tiny carved figurines of each of
you uh one of them comes running up to
you and says
about it
look at homes
very poorly made dwarf uh wearing your
signature magic shield
[Music]
that's cute yeah
beard's off
dad the beard is all off and the kid
turns
listen it's totally fine yeah
you put him in his place
it's totally fine
was that really necessary
well come come come darlings let me see
you let me see you and she walks up to
you applejack and she says
you look incredible oh thank you
we haven't been giving you too much
trouble have they
no not at all
maybe this one
[Laughter]
you know
you've been going easy on the ale right
it's
she kind of looks you up and down and
she's like are you sure well it's hard
to travel with that much
so i kind of ran low like a lot of
excuses
enough get you all right yeah a window
nearby of the tavern swings open and
stella a little halfling she's about
four feet tall with frizzy red hair why
would you like a pint is what you'd like
very much so ah coming right through the
pace for all pipes around eh yes stella
yes yes yes yes and the star looks and
she says wait
business first pints
second
it's i assure you we've made all of your
favorites
she leans in close and says i haven't
wanted to alarm the town's people
but something has been amiss lately
someone has been robbing graves in the
cemetery what
yes
every morning we wake up there are fresh
holes and the bodies are missing
[Music]
i work so hard on that
i know it's it it was a lovely ceremony
and thank you for your restraint for
minimal handstands
i'm just trying to i'm trying to lighten
the mood
well you know it doesn't always need
his father before him a cartwheel but i
remember i saw them all
so what do we have to do oh no what are
we going to do then
we should
this is close to home so i'm curious
you're furious i offered prayers to the
morning lord lathander that help would
arrive and sure enough the four of you
returned home it must be meant to be
right yes i say so that's what's meant
to be is these points
is meant to
be stella my god it is so good to see
you what has it been a year
yeah
you're so beautiful
pick up on this later
back to business
okay fine i know you've been traveling
i'm sure you're weary um we made sure
that all of your houses are prepped and
cleaned
have a drink have some food and then
it's going to be dark soon
maybe take a look okay at the cemetery
yes great great that sounds that sounds
not spooky i'm thinking well i'm there
were you afraid no no no he's afraid
he's always joking i think he's known
that's why he never visits me at work
seriously he makes me come to him
afterwards because like he never wants
to
as an aside you are a paladin not only
are you literally incapable of fear as
long as your friends are around you
they're incapable of fear as well so
you're lying you literally have a
radiant aura
it's unfair really yeah
my friends love me
so i don't know
it's kind of great well okay we'll have
a couple of drinks should we should we
have a few drinks maybe maybe there's a
few maybe there's a few people we can
talk to
you let's see be nice get a little loose
and then yeah yeah yeah just check out
this pre-game three games what do you
think ladies
[Music]
we're gonna go and have some drinks
perfect i'm going to um rally the town
watch make sure i've had people watching
all night recently to see if they could
spot anything you all
indulged wonderful
and then i can find me okay perfect
thank you thank you
good to see you again sorry we were
really grumpy no it's i'm tired thank
you yeah you know
i'm sorry about the the ale comment that
you think you look wonderful you do it's
as you make your way into the tavern
stella has laid out a buffet spread that
probably could feed 20 people or just
one of me or
two two two of you she's at least double
well
i'll take off there's
assorted roast beasts
pheasant pig there's pies cakes so that
anything that you could dream of all of
your favorites have been made great
welcome back stella
well she's just she's just worried about
everyone you know that's her job really
just keep an eye on everything stella
this pie is i mean just these desserts
look beautiful ah you're flattering all
the handling just talking talking and
enjoying
how did you get this gamun like this how
do you get it like that that's the
secret family recipe yeah i said i got
to keep some things to myself you have
to twist your arms so it's only only a
little bit you never know i might like
it
[Laughter]
i
you know strange things happen once
you've had a bit of hail
you never know till you try um yes no
you all enjoy
yourselves and if you need anything i'll
be here just you live in the moon
so it's a cheers
cheers
delicious amazing lady applejack
while
they're all eating and drinking and
rambling
you hear
[Music]
coming from the kitchen where stella
just went
[Music]
what do you want to do what do you want
to do once she calls
i heard someone in the kitchen in the
kitchen this yellow one too stella yeah
was choking like what
oh i hear that's what they don't listen
wait no we have to go find that's what
those things
we should investigate yeah
all seriousness stella might be in
trouble we should go or someone else
pardon me about you
you
as a grave clear you chose that name is
so funny
because again you know gayton was taken
as a well-known demigod
of entertainment and performance the
gayten yes literally almighty
the almighty is
you as a grave cleric have an innate
connection to the weave of life and
death that's funny and understanding
anything that defies that link between
life and death you have an innate sense
for the presence of the undead
for one of
his
you are as wise as it gets honestly
that's great and one thing you realize
there are undead in this building
you feel it
yeah i thought i had some goosebumps
before but i thought it was just me like
getting really excited about the
physiology
uh
well you're hearing that i thought i
felt something before i think
things are added things are adding up
for you
i'm going to go to the kitchen
yes nothing like that should be
happening anywhere near here especially
not stellar good friends so i'm going to
go to the kitchen perfect
as you
push the door open
on the ground you are confronted by a
horrifying sight
stella yeah you think it's stella it's a
stella shaped something oh my god he's
wrapped in what looks like
rotting
meat
and as you notice coming out from under
the tables and ovens
what looks like skin
that has been pulled off of the bone is
sliding
forward oh god and i'm gonna need all of
you to roll initiative
so
on your sheet you should have an
initiative there that will be plus
something
i just wrote it i rolled into 18. did
you really yeah very fast and you were
actually oh i see
uh and i'm gonna go for the monsters
there um
joe kiri you are actually feels great it
feels good yeah it feels good how does
it feel to be joking
these boneless abominations are crawling
out coming from each direction and one
of them is apparently smothering stella
to death
what would you like to do i'm gonna kill
it right you want to shoot it with your
bow i want to shoot it with my magic bow
you
do have a very impressive magic bow it's
a dragon wing long bow so when you draw
it it looks like a dragon's wing flexing
and flames erupt around the arrow as you
shoot that's badass first roll your
attack for me you are very very good
with this bow
now for you in particular you are what
is called a groom stalker so this is
when you shine when you are ambushing in
the first round of combat you actually
get to attack more times and you hit
harder this is something specifically
you do
get in there so what'd you get on that
first one michael 25. perfect you
actually get to attack three times so
hit it for me
four times
21 21 also gonna be a hit and give me
one more one more
[Music]
it's 26.
again
just to give you an idea 30 is godlike
success and you got a 26. so these are
very precise
so they're under your damage you're
going to click that for me three times
that's 12 12. whoa
again again
that's 11. 11. perfect
12. again
you come in
three flaming arrows go and slam into
this thing and it
unwraps there on the ground and stops
moving and you see stella looks like
oh
there's more of them
is there anything else you would like to
do
do you guys see that yeah
that was cool
i'd like to comfort stella perfect she
very much is holding on to you and lady
applejack okay
he has shot the first one of these but
it looks like there's four more in the
room that are crawling out
what would you like to do i want to stab
them
i want to stab always the right answer
is so funny
um
as an assassin rogue you are
particularly good at attacking something
that hasn't had a chance to act yet
basically like you catch things
flat-footed and gank them is really your
thing
so next to your weapon there there's
going to be a plus go ahead and click
that for me there it'll be a plus some
number your weapon is called a rapier of
wounding so you have a magic sword that
when you hurt people the wounds don't
heal
yeah perfect there you go so you did
this the best you possibly could
incredible as you lo i'm not even gonna
make you roll this because i know how
hard you hit is you lunge forward
actually you tell me would lady
applejack explode this thing or is she
so precise that it's just like a little
hole
in and out i feel like she'll explode it
yeah yeah like just go ahead
go for it well this thing already didn't
have any bones
but
lady applejack lunges forward and it
essentially explodes
it's a splatter against the wall
and you can still attack again because
you killed the first one in one shot so
go ahead give it to me again
[Music]
that's fantastic 24.
yes more than enough all right so uh
click on that number there next that'll
be 1d8 you see that there click on that
i'm going to roll your sneak attack
damage for you here so you don't have to
worry about it
how much damage did you get
how much sorry nine nine perfect i'm
waiting on your sneak attack to come
through cause it is a lot of dice you
have 7d6 that you roll for sneak attack
which is a lot like a lot a lot uh the
first one explodes in a flash you're on
the second one and stab it and just
stops moving
they're on the ground
unfortunately
it is now the bonelesses time to attack
and they do not take too kindly to what
joe kiri has done
when does anyone ever that is true and
unfortunately for you joe carey i also
rolled a natural 20. oh
so
joe as you were comforting stella no and
she's like
you all see
the boneless wraps up and begins
squeezing joe kiri for 10 points of
damage
keep track of that and you will see your
friend is being squeezed and suffocated
you are still pretty stout you're still
in the fight but uh but you have been
harmed uh lady applejack
uh
another one does the same thing to you
having just obliterated two of them one
falls from the ceiling
and wraps you up and falls to the ground
and starts squeezing you as well you
guys gonna end points of damage in a
second at any point
are they gonna help hopefully okay
ten points of damage ten ten points
search it here
your friends got off to a really great
start right but now they're kind of
having some problems of their own
what would you like to do i
um
we had i'd like to save them but i also
know what i want to know what the hell
is going on too
like no but i wonder cuz like we listen
here's the other thing we killed them
you guys killed them without even trying
to speak
with them do they speak i guess they
have not made any noises outside of like
pamper dude i've seen this stuff all the
time i sense this stuff okay so so i'm
gonna play it safe and save them thank
you try to save them go ahead and roll
your first attack okay can i okay
you as a paladin you are a holy warrior
so you have the ability to do something
called a smite where when you hit them
you can basically set off a divine
explosion of damage
rule of three
unfortunately you have to hit to be able
to smite so sir chad as you're basically
trying not to accidentally cut the head
off of one of your friends here
which one of them are you attempting to
save not to make you pick favorites it
would be weird if some sort of piece
in my head i was closest to joe perfect
perfect you know what
let's roll let's roll the physical dice
okay grab one of these
yes that's the one and roll it in the
box here in front of you in this one yep
four are you
you know
however you have a pretty significant
bonus that may be enough let me let me
see
uh
that's rough
believe it or not believe it or not you
were such a capable warrior that is
enough to hit it with your you have a
pike a long sharp spear with a hook on
one end that you stab into it now
important question would you like to use
your smite absolutely
perfect again i'm gonna roll that for
you here because you also um
do quite a lot of damage honestly
so i'm going to roll that for you you
roll the damage for me where it says
that 1d10 plus
we'll do the physical dice you want to
tin sometimes that is one of these ones
looks kind of oh oh like a dime yep
yep that's it roll that one
you okay ladies i'm fine
i'm fine you might not get into you're
not
you might not be fine that is true
actually he's going to be okay it is you
who uh there is one other ability you
have uh just for your own let's keep
trying edification no no no you've hit
it you've hit it okay um
you also get to attack a third time
because as a polar master you stand
twice and then hit with the butt of the
weapon so roll that 20 for me again uh i
can't which one is that sorry which one
that one right there this one that i'm
holding that's the one yep roll it there
are there multiple d20s on the table yes
there are two oh god have two you might
even have four i think i have a lot yeah
obviously
four
four four
again
that actually is enough yeah okay you
have a pretty significant bonus so you
do hit it twice now sweet would you like
to smite it twice would you like to set
up your i would love to smite it i love
this life
joe kiri hi
you're being strangled to death
and your friend very ineffectively
swings the first time and the second
time you're pretty sure he's about to
cut your head off as it's coming down
and at the last second there's a
blinding flash of light and
the boneless smeared across the wall
exploded sorry it was sorry
it wasn't it was it was a struggle for
me
pardon me belching yes yes
there is one of these things left yeah
is
what would you like to do and it's it's
messing up her absolutely well i know
that the first priority is making sure
that everybody in my group is safe so
i'm going to try and get it get it off
i'm going to try and attack it
would you like to hit it with your
mainstream would you like to cast one of
your spells
what are my spells your guiding bolt is
kind of your your main i see that what
can i do with my guiding bolts it is a
blast of energy that you will shoot out
if you hit not only will you damage the
target you make it easier for the next
person to damage the target i'm gonna go
with that i want to see your player okay
click that plus next to the guiding bolt
running bolt i roll
a 19. that is more than enough to hit so
you know what let's roll some more of
these physical dice great four of those
uh d6's for the square one
yep roll those all together roll them
all yup
i got a three three three and a five
minutes
14 points of damage uh
that does not quite finish it off
it's not quite finished okay that's fine
that's fine but because you cast a spell
that is actually the only thing you can
do is cast that's okay i'll catch that
spell however
joe carey
now the one remaining boneless is
glowing with light around it uh giving
you an opportunity to finish it off if
you want i'll finish it off so you are
going to roll why would you learn
something can i talk to it it has not
said anything i don't think i want to
kill it yeah okay so because he hit it
with a guiding hole you have what is
called advantage you get to roll two of
these and take the higher one so roll
two of these twenties you're welcome and
you take the higher number between the
two
thirteen thirteen that is more than
enough it is with your bow uh and then
you're gonna roll one more time for me
for your second arrow
12. again more than enough we've got
this two more arrows
the flames start igniting and burning
its gross undid form
and stella is just sitting there shaking
covered in go like
i said um
all right it's okay it's okay
baby baby
baby baby baby baby baby
this is awesome
very much buries her head in in to your
quite frankly furry test
and also save that give me reception
perception
yep
i'm gonna roll right next to it actually
it's gonna go everything all right i'm
gonna hold a ten ten ten
not noticing too much is in your skills
thirteen thirteen perfect
i have a roll of 14. 14. all right
oh no 19. 19 19. yep because i added to
it um
as stella is kind of freaking out a
little bit here search head yeah
outside
you hear
screaming
in footsteps right now yeah yeah
footsteps and screaming
from nowhere footsteps running away from
the scratch yes coming from outside the
cab okay
well i'm gonna go
see what's going on outside be careful i
will i'll try
as you run outside
it's terrible
from the water
that is surrounding hawk's end
you see
undead are coming out of it
zombies shambling forward waterlogged
but not just zombies
parts of zombies
there's arms and hands that are just
disconnected from anything else coming
up out of the water onto the shore and
the people of the town are screaming and
running some of the watch have pulled
out swords and bows and have our
lighting up torches they're kind of no
match for this though sir chadwick so
what would you like to do
whoa are you gonna tell your friends
i'm gonna go and let them know that
there's a horde of undead coming towards
us
thank you guys
there's a horde of undead coming towards
us right now okay yeah the moment i've
been waiting for they're coming from the
water
coming up out of the water but they all
seem to be coming shorter from the
northeast side of the water okay all
coming out that way okay
okay forgive me but you have a tendency
to be absolutely you didn't see this
coming at all
you don't understand how this works it's
not it's not like a spider sense it's
it's more of like uh
it's more of like i can't predict what's
happening but i understand when
something is happening so right now i'm
off the walls like right now like my
chest i you wouldn't believe it's like a
major anxiety attack right now and i
would appreciate if you didn't make fun
of me can we get you something um
just more beard yeah yeah yeah
i think i might stay did you say you
want to stay in here yeah i want to stay
you got to chill out in here you're not
going to go help
did you see what happened last night
so
you lady applejack are incredibly sneaky
so if you want to skulk around outside
there's a pretty good chance no one can
see you if you do yeah i think that's
what i might do do this for me roll one
of these 20s for me okay
we're gonna see just how good of a job
you do sneaking yep
roll that for me okay
oh okay
great so here's the problem
you never know if you're doing a good
job or a bad job right so you all have
your friends the lethal assassin who's
like
just kind of goes stomping out skipping
thinking she's a ghost
oh my god great it's so
embarrassing what do we do what do we do
now what what is she doing ghost
nobody's ever going to see you
all right well now she's gone what are
we going to do um
is it would you all like to head outside
i would love to head i need to go
outside
you should we should face this yeah
absolutely
a quick thing
am i allowed to ask
uh
ostello who what is going on
absolutely
um
what would you like to ask
do you know
no do you know uh
have you seen these kind of monsters
before
or do you know what's happening why
would i know what's happening during the
adventure
i'm going to barricade myself out in the
tower that's all right okay you should
stay there
she's a mess
thank you joe hi make sure you return to
me
okay
as you guys come out you see the scene
as described undead hordes coming out of
the water first thing i think we need to
oh are you continuing no what were you
going first thing i think we need to do
is try to get everybody out of here
since they're coming from the northeast
i say we rally the towns and get them
off the south bridge perfect what would
you like to say uh we're gonna tell them
uh guys
look at all this
it's not coming from over there run that
way if you can barricade yourselves in
houses do it if you can make it to the
bridge go don't worry about supplies
we'll we can we can rally that later
just get out of here south bridge
south and i know what you guys are
thinking yes i did have a night out with
stella okay that's not the behind we can
figure it out okay fine okay fine south
[Music]
that was no collateral damage when we
try to kick ass perfect perfect thank
you brilliant
where's she i don't know where she was
no she's pretty she's playing in the
water
[Laughter]
however i'm going to keep you guys in
the same order that we were going before
so um that would make it your turn oh my
god
uh again there's zombies everywhere
what would you like to do
you never go wrong with stabbing
if you want to do something else you can
but you know that's what is that
something else i could do check like
yours
you are very well your skills um
you're very good at sneaking well it's
supposed to be you're very good
at disguising yourself making you look
like someone else you can actually turn
invisible
if you like
yeah i think i might turn them can i
turn invisible and stab them
surely yes but if you stab them you will
reappear you will stay invisible until
you attack something oh
okay then i might i might just go
invisible okay and disappear for the
time thanks for the help so wow
she's testing it out i guess you take
care of me whatever
i gotta put me first
very valid uh you know you got to find
the commander right
that's the thing you do uh perfect lady
applejack turns invisible
and she makes a cool sound as well
apparently
yes your friend has disappeared yes the
townspeople appear to be listening to
you heading south uh again there are
undead hordes all around you uh what
would you like to do could i use my
athletics in some way oh oh or i'm sorry
no please i just got another thing yup
can i pretend
to
be a zombie
and try to like follow them to wherever
they're going
oh you could because my perception's
pretty you're a pretty seasoned
adventurer though and the undead are
very dumb like okay they're not going
towards anything they thirst okay
i just want i just in case in case i
needed to go undercover super logical
okay
so this might be an attack situation
uh
can i use my athletics in any way so
what athletics will let you do is if you
want to grapple them like if you want to
grab one and wrestle it to the ground um
i will tell you just for your own
knowledge something that is just dope
that you've got is you have a spell
called find greater steed where you can
summon a magical creature to ride like a
griffin a pegasus a dire wolf a rhino a
saber tooth tiger like you can just
summon something dope to ride if you
would like to do that can i attack while
i'm on top of that and my next turn
that's cool literally i'm gonna call a
griffin you like a griffin yeah what
does your griffin look like when it
shows up uh
oh she's a bit of a lion body of a bird
i was thinking like hummingbirds super
long note like super sharp long nose
and then um yeah the body of the line
and big uh yeah big wings like the buzzy
wings like a hummingbird kind of wings
yeah exactly
it's a hummingbird griffin
i feel like this is something so jade's
probably done before does it have a name
when you summon your your hummingbird
yeah uh uh
[Music]
raw
roderick
[Laughter]
rodrick the hummingbird perfect i love
it i love it i'm gonna give roderick in
here for you yeah
do i roll for that excellent no no this
is what i do okay got it got it okay uh
but presumably you want to hop on the
back of it i would love to hop on the
back of that perfect
hi what's up dude hey
that's true it's purely transaction with
robert exactly
i pay him i pay him at the end of each
ride
it's like it's basically an uber i pay
it's a ride share
exactly
uh pardon me belgium what would you like
to do
uh right now i just i'm just sad right
now because right honestly i see all
this happening these creatures are
supposed to be resting they're supposed
to be
like at peace and right now they're not
and they're putting themselves and
everybody else in danger and i'm pissed
you as a cleric have an ability that is
called turn undead
i might do it i don't know if you can
just make them leave
and you're actually a high enough level
cleric you can make them basically force
them to leave and if they're low enough
level they will not just leave they will
be destroyed okay by your holy
intervention this is insanely convenient
yeah i mean what a great unbelievable is
my element this is what i need this is
what we all need meanwhile where's
estara is she getting out with them
because i feel like she should debrief
with us or yes she is rallying people
moving themselves
okay so right yeah i would like i want
to talk to these guys i want to be able
to communicate i want them out of here
right so it is your intent to turn them
correct yes
um oh yeah you can you can what is that
what spell is that um it is an ability
that you've got called turn undead
perfect yeah
what so you brandish your holy symbol
glowing radiant
what do you say
to turn
these undead fiends okay i need to
relate to them because they're just sad
they're lost they don't want to be here
either and i say guys
you have each other
you don't need this this is something
you've had before but you don't need it
now
it's you've moved on from this and it's
not healthy to be lingering here right
now i will guide you i will be here to
hold your hand but or your leg you don't
got hands no more but i will be here for
you i know i'm i know it's rough
like you need to you've had your time
and you can't take it from other people
as you finish your heartfelt speech
is that your shambling
you all see
what color is the light that comes out
of pardon me belgian you're a grave
cleric you're a cleric of death there's
a cleric of death but the thing is
people misunderstand death death isn't
scary death is a part of life like we're
here all together and it's amazing and
so it's a warm it's a warm sunset orange
that that wafts as as the day ends into
a peaceful night
as this light rolls out from you you are
strong enough that you will destroy all
of these undead but break me it was
right
you were coming from a place of love and
it is your intent to put their spirits
at rest that's what happens yeah you all
noticed the zombies just sort of stop
for us and just kind of lay down amazing
and die wow
and i weep i didn't want to have to do
that i didn't want to do that beautiful
thank you then i say so are we getting
another drink
unfortunately oh god party belching
that's okay
you get a sinking
sickening feeling coming from the south
where i told everybody to go you told
everybody
it is almost like
this attack came from the north it's a
diversion force everywhere it's a
diversion what kind of monster would do
oh my god what did i do
what did i do
it's going to be a blood ball nice guys
we need to go we need to run to the rest
of you it's like yeah we won and no we
need to go
we're running do we get do we can we get
her back or she kind of
lady applejack's coming
she's coming we're all going we're
running we don't know she's here can i
say
i heard everything and i decided that i
needed to help you guys thank you yeah
let's go yeah as you all head south
right across the bridge
you see
just on the other side of it
what looks like
a tear has been ripped into reality
great there is a jagged black
line
with black energy
rolling out of it
um
maybe shoot something into it first oh
what if you hit
it and okay i'll do a quick equipment
yeah what do they call it like what's
like a really normal thing like you know
when people are at a party i'm like i'm
gonna do a little like i'm gonna do a
round like i'm gonna do the rounds yeah
i'm gonna do the rounds
okay so you run into i'm gonna run into
come back and see what the vibe is and
then if it's cool you guys come in we
have drinks with the towns okay great
come on we got it right we're gonna fly
in i will find yes roderick flies in oh
i'm with my i mean you're you're right
you are going with russia right right
correct right correct
you fly in and he doesn't come back out
[Music]
we've been waiting for
he should be popping up you should be
back by now i should should we i guess
we might as well do it
at least we know that everybody like
anybody who remained on it is anybody
still here
everybody is apparently
everybody yes
so can i call out to see if anybody's
there the only person that is still
there i actually even stella went
because you sent her south too stella's
gone oh i'm gonna go
gotta go
we gotta go i can't leave them in there
without me in there any of them any of
the guards no none of all the guards
everything yeah we're inviting a third
okay
okay
[Laughter]
immediately
you're somewhere else
it's
cold
like the wintertime i wonder it looks
like hawk sand i wonder
but it's not
hawks
it's the buildings you recognize
but they are broken and dilapidated
overgrown with vines
like they haven't been lived in for
centuries the sky is black
in everywhere in all directions i
thought it was like four it looks
so
hopeless
the only thing that you see because the
portal behind you has vanished
you do lay eyes on your friend chadwick
hey bud you did try and come back but
the portal was gone yeah the moment you
came through
oh it's gone we can't get out so we're
stuck in here right you are
and you hear
chanting what
oh
difficult to make out wait wait wait
wait holistic chanting are we talking
like
[Laughter]
it's difficult to tell it's like it's
coming from everywhere in nowhere all at
once yeah it's like an aura okay
i gotta say right now guys i feel worse
than i ever like i feel
horrible
i just stayed in visually anxious i like
this bro i really wish i could just curl
up in bed i
i don't really feel motivated right now
okay and um
it uh it's clear to me that there's
something really dark and really bad
here
not fun really having a manic depressive
on your team is it
he is literally a clearer
it seems to be coming from all
directions at once
[Applause]
i hate that
i hate it
oh no no no no no no no
no
you all have made your
[Music]
oh
i assure you wait
everywhere
will be like this place oh no
good
well that's great i guess we should get
used to it yeah the chanting gets
louder oh
and you finally can make out what
they're saying
hail
vaccinations
okay
first things first where is everyone
you don't see
anyone
stella
just because you're an actor you think
you can do that
i knew what this was when i introduced
you it wasn't easy it was
such portuguese
sorry i'm sorry
literally what the fans paid to see
[Laughter]
if she can she doesn't respond so the
brando's not really like it's not
helping you just i mean you wish you
were brandon i wish
i can't bring it back
oh you know that one is special to you
she's a friend yeah
oh if you touch her
i swear to god
[Music]
i'll let the halfling go
if you give yourself freely well i'll
i'll give myself i'm going to give
myself i'll give myself
no one asked you i'll give myself freely
in the sky
floating overhead
you all see a terrible form
begin to take shape look at that he is
withered that's
[Music]
he is withered in gaunt
pale decaying gray flesh
gross with a white milky right eye in
his left eye and left hand are missing
it's byzine
you can see through his rib cage almost
through his body in his flowing robes
are open and inside of him inside his
body there's a book
a black
book
that
that makes me feel weird that feels like
an epicenter with all my troubles let's
guess what the book is that feels like
an epicenter of everything that's ever
been wrong with my life
joe
jerry
you must thank me a great fool
[Laughter]
you know what let's go ahead and roll
initiative one more time
give me one of these dice or you can
roll it there and dnd beyond is you come
face to face finishing with it i rolled
a 15 vec now 15 for pardon me belching
five five chad
22 chadwick yes you are 25 for carrying
oh
yeah
25
uh
25th birthday
25 for karen perfect all right
perfect perfect perfect all right
uh you can go first again as a gloom
stalker this is when you shine right at
the beginning yeah so you can attack
three times
just gonna go with the bow just yeah
just i'm going to hit that that plus 12.
we're going to do this it's like uh
if you would pull out a d6
for me that's 19.
let's see hang on let me make sure 19 is
enough to hit him it is not i know
the arrow flies what should have been
center mass and just passes through his
rotting decrepit ribs and just flies
right past him
and he looks at you and says
perfect
but now he knows i'm here but you're
gonna go again oh yeah you can you can
three total come on what are you going
to try again what are you going to get
17. that is also not enough come on lies
wide one more time
can we focus in here yeah oh i'm focused
okay
it's going to be a big number okay okay
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
uh perfect so i mean did you roll your
damage for me with this where's that
eight in that six yeah
so take that and you're gonna roll that
manifest today
can you give them another eight you got
it yeah right there you can roll all
three of those
all right it's a three it's a three it's
a
six perfect 15 perfect perfect perfect
that one does hit him right in the chest
and he just looks down at it and says
fine
let's do it your way
17 for
all of you do it eight eight seven seven
sixteen six teams
that is not enough
vecna raises his hands and you all feel
the light being sucked down
again
42 points well all of
every
it's a significant hit a significant hit
so what would i be yeah that would be oh
no uh but lady applejack it is your turn
okay
that sucks guys i'm on 53 now mm-hmm
uh
um ladies and gentlemen
he
is currently up in the air where you
don't have an easy way to get to him
uh it's almost like he knows you're
dangerous
but what you can do
is you have a spell called fairy fire
what that means is you can basically
light him up to make him easier for your
friends to hit him until somebody finds
a way to get him out of the air let me
help you guys out
[Applause]
he starts glowing and he looks down at
his hands and he goes
you
scent
plenty
of souls my way applejack
and now
that you face vechna
you don't have the courage to strike it
me yourself
[Applause]
uh it sounds like you're crying so
called the wambus
because she's crying
anything else lady applejack until they
get him out of the air somehow it's
gonna be tough
uh
[Laughter]
would you like to try and find the
villagers maybe oh oh yes okay go
perfect go do that
roll one of those yep
tell me
[Laughter]
lady applejack temporarily stones
yeah when someone makes a joke about you
and you like take five minutes and
you're like that was mean
i can't move on from that
it is unfortunately actually beckner's
turn
well he is very powerful that's why he
has something uh he has something called
legendary action so he can just sort of
do stuff whenever he wants this should
be good
now here's the thing uh-uh uh
not everyone at the table has played
before i'm not gonna i'm gonna bust
anybody out but this is supposed to be a
happy occasion which you
think would mean i should go easy mm-hmm
problem is this is vector and vector's
not gonna go easy yeah back that's not
gonna go you could
you might but that's okay because you
all are glorious heroes glorious heroes
vechna
is
he pulls his finger out
[ __ ]
lightning leaps out
going towards you as he casts chain
lightning
so
all of you give me dex saves
dexterity i'm not dexterity series
uh
lady applejack
uh
good are particularly agile so i love it
it's very difficult to hit you with this
sixteen six twenty three twenty five
minutes
that's not gonna
applejack you were able to spring out of
the way basically by ducking behind your
friend so you can kind of take it into
the chest
five
do i have a shield
your shield is a pretty kick-ass one you
do
in fact your
your shield specifically can help you
against things like this i know um you
get to roll twice okay and take the
higher one of those uh two twenties yeah
well yeah you've already rolled once you
get roll once again
i'll roll again
11.
oh man
well the good news is lady applejack
gets out of the way let's
let's start with a win here oh you know
let's start with a win uh the rest of
you are unfortunately not great yeah do
what you do just run
well just uh pray that i roll poorly
that's all you got to do what you do
best if that last time i got attacked
there's like almost half our hit points
yeah there's i probably won't have that
there there's a pretty big screen
you guys have have varying levels of
tankiness yeah so let's see we've got a
high constitution that's not terrible
that's not terrible there's only 25
points of lightning damage okay it's not
terrible but not lady applejack oh okay
22. 25. five points of lightning damage
i have 21 hit points left is that right
you currently have 21 though okay
perfect i'm at 48 am i like 50.
that's impossible i have 115 at start he
is he is oh okay yeah i started with 80
something you're not all you're not all
the same improvements 25 damage i'm on
28.
vecna looks down at all of you and says
you could just give up
join me
serve me
will make it sporting for you
and he starts to float down towards the
ground
he's cocky
this is where we get him because he's in
popularity if i were to just obliterate
all of you out of hand would it
[Laughter]
take him on yeah i don't know this guy
kind of backs himself i might join him
oh this guy's awesome i kind of like
this he has stella i don't join him he
has stella pardon me belching it is your
turn it's my turn i want to don't join
him sorry
i see you thinking about me
ponder it
when joke here
this is what you must understand i need
you can live and serve me
or you can die
and serve me
yes pardon me belgium it is your turn
you don't scare me
because i am not afraid of death
that's what i have against you you live
off of fear a fear of what
nothing but
malarkey that's all it is
that's all it is and i would have gotten
lucky
i'm the greatest in the multiverse i'm
the master of death
oh the master of death
that it's nothing it means nothing not
to me at least and i will a guiding bolt
do anything here so
yes
you you have you have a few options
you have a few things look through those
options for me uh yes you can um
you can guiding bold him um you can uh
try and heal your friends um you can do
a pretty pretty significant amount of
healing to everyone if you so choose
basically you can heal one person for a
lot or everyone for a little here's the
thing
i would love to heal everybody for a
little but you're all so low on health
anyway that if i do that and he hits us
once again we're still going yeah i
think it's a waste of it i think it's a
waste of a go perfect however um i'm
trying to think of who here has the best
shot
of messing this dude up if i were to
genuinely get a good amount of help
going but i think if anybody here is
gonna be any match it's gonna be me
sorry guys i know it sounds selfish but
no no no no i think it doesn't sound so
what i will tell you tell me now
next round if you want to coordinate
with lady applejack
there might be some stuff you could do
she's already going in this round
you guys can do something right now you
got you got your guiding booth there's a
guiding bolt if i said a guy well his
way it ups the damage for the next turn
for her it does yeah um you also have
something called dawn where you can call
down just like a burning pillar of
sunlight that will stay there on him if
you want also what will that spill it'll
burn
you know what honestly i think i want to
go for like a hail mary here and i want
to i want
him out of here and i think the best way
of doing it is to link up here i know
we've had our differences but i hope
you'll pull through okay
still here yeah i know right
now i'm gonna go with the guiding bolts
perfect now um again since i i'm
introducing this in layers of complexity
of course you can actually cast a bigger
guiding bolt you can cast it at a higher
level
the biggest of bolts i assume you want
as big as the bolts roll this d20 for me
finish rolling on the screen or can i
just roll here uh whichever you like
this is more fun yeah
13. um that actually is enough whoa yes
that is enough to hit him you are gonna
roll 10 d6 10. you can either you can do
it here 10 or 10 of those bad boys five
six
yep all right get ready for some math hi
math coming in
from the guiding bolt we've got we got a
six mm-hmm we got a three mm-hmm we got
a three mm-hmm we got two twos mm-hmm
we got a one mm-hmm we got a five mm-hmm
we got a four mm-hmm and we have two
ones give me the total
[Laughter]
let me show you easy trick by the way
yeah i think 29 29 perfect all right i
don't need any easy tricks 29 all right
perfect i was definitely using my
thingies to count on the table i don't
know if the camera caught
there is no shame i mean like that's
what god made i wanted to sound cool
like i was doing it in my head
you know but it wasn't that is why that
is
that's where i found that dude
i
perfect you blast him and he begins to
glow radiantly and just looks down at
his hands again and uh actually roll
that d20 one more
it's a 13 again okay perfect you shot
him it's just he had an advantage
because
perf just for curiosity's sake however
he is now glowing sir chadwick
with the guiding bolt uh it is your turn
he is undead you want to attack you are
good at this uh roll your two attacks uh
run up on him
so two two to twenty two d20s yep you
just roll them both
eight
uh that is not going to be enough even
with your significant attack bonus come
on buddy mm-hmm
20 20 nat 20. oh no so no no this is
okay this is good this is good that was
my thinking face that's not that wasn't
uh
sucks for you so
you are about to inflict a significant
amount of damage on right now
i assume you would like to smite him yes
i assume you would like to hit him as
hard as you possibly can absolutely
right perfect um
you know what let's stack this up let me
give you the benefit of the doubt here
you have a few spells you can use that
would actually make this worse if you
like um
you have uh what is called a branding
smite where your sword will catch on
fire any other spells
not well you have other spells but not
that
it's relevant to this yeah i'll try that
okay perfect okay so you roll that uh
your damage there which is i believe
that was a d10 d10 plus six roll that
and then you're gonna double that number
70. come on uh so
19. um and then your smite is going to
go off he is undead so you hit him for
extra
and
let's see how hard you were gonna smite
him
so you hit him for 19. and he looks down
for a second and opens his mouth like
he's about to say something and
the smite goes off a blinding flash
where you hit him for another 60 points
of damage
blowing chunks off of him and staggering
him backwards and this is the first time
he looks at you and you see the
slightest hint of fear in his eyes
that's awesome
as he stumbles backwards here from your
divine smite perfect this is a good
round for you guys uh but that brings us
to the top of round two
joe kiri it is your turn again uh becna
is on the ground now your friend has
engaged him what would you like to do is
that you mentioned earlier that these
two could team up yes can i team up with
someone and to kind of do something bad
to him there's a specific ability that
he has that works really well with an
ability that she has that's that's
that's why so it's not that you can't
cooperate it just so happens they
synergize quite well okay okay we've got
a lot of money here yeah yeah right like
started casting yeah that's okay i guess
i'll stick to um to shooting him
shoot him roll it twice him again
so that's 15 to start with that is not
enough to hit him mm-hmm
go for it again it worked last time it
did work awesome
and you see the arrow arcing right
towards his one remaining eye
he just breaks it throws it down oh he's
making a fool of me yeah
you were the fool to think you could
face that
i hate him i hate him
uh
how many points have you got left i've
got 28. how many of you got left no you
got i've got 48. and lady applejack how
much 21. 21. 21. 21.
i'm completely i thought it might be
yeah
no it's kind of it might really not be
no he's going to do it oh you give me
con saves again he is going to he's
going to hit you all with the life
training again
here's the problem you all
he does 42 points of damage if it works
he does 21 even if you succeed
he's going to stop sir chadwick no
matter what lady applejack has a chance
to get out of this though
well death is a kind of complex process
you're about to be knocked unconscious
oh okay you're about to be knocked down
my head all of you so if i if my
headphones are gone it doesn't mean that
i'm like dead correct got it it's a
fairly
complex process of how to die but all of
you give me con saves constitution saves
everybody that constitution yeah that's
where i sh again you can't well um still
give it to me sir chadwick because it
might matter whether or not you're at
zero or nine
eleven eleven what was it eleven eleven
all right fifteen fifteen how many hit
points did lady applejack have 21. okay
perfect uh
all right
lady applejack and sir chadwick
collapsed to the ground all right how
many hit points have you got i've got 11
28 left
you did not make a save that means you
took 42 points in the old
it might pardon me also yeah your
friends collapsed yeah around you
i say 21 points 21 points well no
actually i don't think 15. 42 total
how many do you have i have seven
seven
your friends collapse
wekner looks down at them
six sorry the
foolishness of mortality
look at you
all your good works
all your grand adventure
only to collapse and ruin
before
me
so
what now
do you think you can strike me down
cleric i fine
try your best
i won't even intervene i have this rage
in this need to just
well not smite because you do that but i
have this rage and need to
just chuck the hammer at full force
towards his head but i understand that
death works in mysterious ways and i
know now that in a time in which i feel
re i think i need to be as selfless as
possible here
um
i need to help
the only way i think is going to work is
that i keep being a team player so i'm
going to use that that healing spell we
talked about before
not like the one the match one like the
one i'm gonna i'm gonna heal the crap
out of her you can do that as a bonus
action it's not gonna handle her by much
but oh we'll get her back to her feet
and you can still do something
so okay
yes you come back to consciousness okay
everything's hurting lady
you're still grievously wounded but you
are back in the fight yes in what else
would pardon me belching like to do i
have to go i gotta i'm not used to
playing magical creatures i'm used to
going like i'm used to going the range
route but i gotta look at these spells
can i i'm gonna do path to the grave
gonna mark him with the path to the
grave
so what that is you are a grave cleric
you can basically make him vulnerable to
the next thing that hurts him yeah the
next step that's right that we were
talking about before yes okay great
you're gonna mark him yeah you're gonna
say anything when you mark him with the
path to the grave
surprise
lady applejack
technically you were unconscious for
your turn but you know again we're here
to have fun so i'm going to go ahead and
let you take your action now
as you get back to your feet it seems
like vectona either hasn't noticed you
or is just ignoring you
so go ahead and roll you can roll twice
and take the higher one
like actually
for real
you are the luckiest
i need you to know something he still
has so many hit points but
this means you were going to do four
times as much damage okay so here's how
this is gonna this is gonna work you
were gonna roll 7d6 so give her seven
seven of these you got a couple there so
yeah i think you have enough six three
seven six seven seven and then give her
one d8 if you would there just help her
find yeah that's um that's this guy
right uh it is cool and you're also
going to give her one of these triangles
give her d4
would you clear all those out just make
it make it simple
okay you're gonna roll all of that and
you're gonna do four times that much
damage
[Laughter]
geez
i cannot believe that you were actually
literally about to kill him okay
i think 26
26.
so now you do four times 26 damage yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can do whatever that
would be
i'm gonna do a hundred and four points
of damage to him
he had
a hundred and two left
you did something
tell me what it looks like when lady
applejack kills vector
what does she do to him so lady
applejack
goes in with the stab he goes in with
the class um
she slices his head off
then she steps in his eyeball
an eyeball
then he goes in she goes in for like a
step with like a head split like
fun yeah
just like that
you see he opens his mouth like he's
about to say something else and
down the middle yeah
and his body
collapses and that book falls out
oh the book and everything around you
begins to ripple in shimmer and the
darkness passes away
and you're back in hawk's end and you
see all the people are standing there
looking confused
but the book joe
a book
as you're staring at it it looks like it
is made
out of flesh of some kind with the face
like a growling demon carved in the
cover of it and there are metal bindings
down it and it's like it's whispering to
you
joe
joe
joe
oh i've got to read this yeah
and as joe reaches out for the book of
vile darkness well i didn't know it was
cool
that is a wonderful place for us
gotta save something for the sequel
right
congratulations to you all
congratulations to you yes you killed
becca yes
i need you to know i absolutely would
have killed all of them
it might not be the end of the story be
like i guess vector wins that's the
ending so
we rolled the dice and landed on a level
20 good time thanks
to the hellfire club for play
glorious lady applejack
thank you at home for watching netflix
geeked uh and until next time go out
there roll some dice and have some fun
thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up honorary hellfire club members
i hope you enjoyed watching us mix it up
with vecna he's a real son of a lich to
deal with and i am not sorry about that
joke you've watched us play now i hope
it inspires you to dig into some dnd at
your table tell amazing stories have
grand adventures and epic battles with
your friends it's my favorite thing in
the world and i think it'll be yours too
remember dnd is for everyone and to help
you get started we're releasing the
vechna dossier a digital manual with
everything you need to bring the
multiverse's most powerful lich to
unlife in your game you can find it on
dnd beyond the official digital tool set
of dungeons and dragons now all you've
got to do is gather some unsuspecting
friends and unleash vechna on them
they'll thank you
eventually
[Music]
[Music]
my name is children munoz i'm an
illustrator and storyteller from
guayaquil ecuador and i get to draw for
a living
you know everybody gets their influences
as they grow up for me when i went to
school i really latched on to people
like up iworks and ozamo dazuka so my
two biggest influence is a combination
of japanese pop culture and classic
american
rubber hose cartoons
for the stranger things uh piece
specifically
um i i originally titled the piece i am
the monster i even essentially fused the
character of 11 and the demogorgon
together
being an artist sometimes especially
like working in in different industries
it can sometimes feel like a rat race
the reminder i always tell myself is
just focus on my voice what i would like
to see put out there in the world
[Music]
you